something's happening to me for months
now I've been having these dreams
nightmares but I think they were
messages your grandmother's there's a
place up north I think we can find you
answers there where are we going back to
where it all began
I need to know the truth or are we
she'd never be our enemy by choice I
know that but what if it's not her
choice necklace that's a locus symbol
[Music]
games play best on Xbox one
[Music]
okay you can't see this
you don't see this
[Music]
[Music]
okay
I'm sorry
[Music]
thanks for coming here
of course can I recommend we maybe get
these people out of here hey just slow
down no fuzz is right we need to move
what he's dead man give her a minute
she'll get her a minute in the raven
that was wrong with you don't we need to
leave
I'm not going excuse me for months now
I've been having these dreams nightmares
but I think they were messages
something's happening to me
to grandmother's enough we'll deal with
this later foster around these people up
they need help there's a place up north
I think we can find you answers there no
absolutely not
we have orders you'll go with me doc
damn it both of you listen I'll go with
her
look if you're missing general notice
okay I'll push Jack the coordinates
they'll corporal you're coming back to
North Fira
that is a direct order well captain
screw your order this isn't about you
it's about me I need to fix this
[Applause]
Hey watch her the necklace
that's a locus symbol yes so she would
never be higher than me my choice I know
that because she would die for us I know
that but what if it's not her choice
[Music]
where are we going back to home again
[Music]
who's ready to play I mean
and
we pray
Hey hey why did you come here with me
what did JT tell you
[Music]
games play best on Xbox one
you